what's happening reject nation we're
gonna watch from our friends of revenue
rock stars loki trailer breakdown easter
eggs
tva the time variants authority and db
cooper
explained excited to check this out new
rockstars
extremely reliable for the deeper cuts
and references and then the occasional i
think you're reaching but
they acknowledged that i think they got
this is eric voss man let's do it
welcome back to me rockstars i'm aaron
voss and loki released its first
official trailer at disney's investor
day
no i will stop thank god a trailer
mischievous and
ragnaroky cannonballing into the lore of
marvel history
such a cool moment mysteries of real
world history turns out davey cooper won
don draper it was
loki which makes me so damn excited for
everything else we're going to attribute
to the god of mischief
santa equals loki probably now i reacted
to this glorious trailer in my reaction
spree in the past
look at those views now we gotta break
this thing down frame by three because
there are a ton of easter eggs like
think about it folks i got nine minutes
out of two seconds back in february
imagine what i can do now
let's get started with familiar shots of
avengers any game when the avengers
revisited loki's arrest during the time
high speed
tony stark butterfingered the tesseract
allowing loki to escape now
we see where he went through a body for
us to
through space now we even end it by
passing through what looks like the eye
of heindall as past trips to the bye
frost
dude eric you're already blowing my mind
function similarly to the bifrost
because until now they have been at
least two
different forms of magic in the mcu one
in infinity stone the other
all father magic that both do the same
thing allow teleportation from anywhere
in the universe but this bypass imagery
suggests to me
that those two magics might really be
linked as many of us have suspected odin
did
possess that tesseract for millennia and
according to children's books in the
thor movie he only crossed that rainbow
bridge when he was bringing the
tesseract to norway back in the old days
so maybe odin derived that by frost
power from that stone
oh look at me going on about the
technicalities of the science of the mcu
when there's a whole trailer to break
down
no i got it
[Music]
this is sand
[Laughter]
okay loki has crash landed in what i
assume to be the gobi desert of mongolia
based on the people who come across
him now i mentioned this in the reaction
but loki's crashing the dune
definitely tony stark
escaping that cave in afghanistan the
moment mr stark
followed plato's allegory of the cave to
escape his narrow world view
to a place of enlightenment as lookie is
now given a second chance at life to do
but it's interesting that loki
crashed he is an experienced by frost
traveler
and with the space stone he should have
nimbly navigated to whatever destination
he wanted to go but
right right the tesseract anymore here
so either this is from a different scene
or something interfered with that travel
knock the tesseract away from him
causing him to crash out at the nearest
mongolian offering
next clip okay
oh there's a lot to get here there's a
lot to get here that's the whole script
do it eric
do it you're taking me somewhere to kill
me
break down the letters this title card
appears in a city of
l's o's k's and i's all different
typefaces like the ones that flicker at
the end i'll get to those good
i know you will experience timelines and
historical causalities this series will
play with it also reflects the way
loki's remains would have been
left in the maintenance new timeline if
you think about it floating in space
among hundreds of
dead as guardians but then we find
ourselves in this elevator shaft of what
i seem to be the tda
time variance authority aka marbles time
cops
actually that sounds cooler than it is
really the tv is like a bureaucracy of
timeline
monitors they oversee and investigate
violations across the various marvel
timelines
they hate kang the avengers meddled with
the timelines
big time in the game but loki as the
escapee
from one of those menlon he would be the
evidence of those violations that the
tva can now contain
actually the real world location here is
the eye-popping colonies
of the marriott marquis in atlanta and i
love how it implies each floor
is a kind of different timeline in the
multiverse with the floor buttons each
represented with a three character
alphanumeric code
j3e iul fe3 lk3
2w1 fhf vg2
u77 te7 gye 2we
3fg and cet t s
l g f three if there is a rhyme or
reason to these it's too soon to tell
i'm sorry
why'd you name all of them three
characters
it's worth noting because if you think
about it they're going through
different realities maybe each floor
designates the three coordinates of
three axes in space
x y and z three dimensions but the
elevators are interesting
if you think that would be a fourth
dimension the axis
of time the one axis that connects
three-dimensional space
in either sides theory relativity am i
breaking your brain i'm sorry
yeah you are i got a headache now uh
symbols down the middle
there is a circle with a line going
through it ghostbusters style an
x three parallel lines actually a little
happy face
directs how this time wonkavader travels
across those timelines it could
stop or freeze a timeline down its
tracks it could crisscross
timelines it could reset timelines to
run
parallel without interference and then
one where it's just like
surprising i know i'm taking some place
to talk
well i don't like to talk but you do
like to lie
which you just did because we both know
you
love to talk
that's hard to say you know time passes
differently here in the tva
what does that mean you'll catch up okay
loki is detained as a prisoner in this
he wears a tv
so great to see you i believe that's his
danger maybe
explosive caller he's with owen wilson's
character the closed captions reveal his
name to me
love it that name is actually the most
recurring manager of the tva in the
comics they all have goofy names the
main
mobius does come from the same
impossible geometric shape that tony
stark conceptualized to crack the code
of time travel and
ending this time in the shape of a
mobius
cool eric
cool i
itself and the fact that movies is about
to show him the end of his timeline
in an alternate life are you confused
you'll catch up
when eric crafted this one he's like
this will be my masterpiece
breakdown
this could be just a red fair but since
we know
this show is hopping through time i
think these chrono monitors are hunting
down a time fugitive and i think the one
they seek is this hooded figure who
drops the lantern attacks the chrono
monitor and the reaction i speculated
this is gonna be someone like doctor
doom since richard
grant is gonna be playing some kind of
villainous character in this show
but based on this person's hands i think
this could be sophia di martino's
character
who i speculated in a set photo
breakdown earlier this year could be
yeah
yeah his soul was transferred to a
female bodybuilder
maybe there is an alternate timeline
where loki is in a female form
in that because was
like jelly is the one you have to hunt
yourself
[Music]
so loki is brought before this awesome
looking courtroom three
looming faces and this judge that is
played by gugu mubatara
she could be one of the known justices
on the tba there's justice peace justice
love justice goodwill but those three
faces
i believe are these same faces that we
see in the giant statues in the entire
courtyard
i'm wondering if these figures could be
connected to the
multiple faces multiple identities of
the living tribunal
the cosmic deity judge that oversees the
universe like perhaps the living
tribunal is the chief justice
who oversees these lower lines my god
because notice behind looking you can
see on the wall it reads three
time court the time court there are
other types of court these aren't just
the tva courts in this building so
there's probably some higher level judge
overseeing other kinds of cosmic crimes
also notice that later in the trailer
she in the chrono monitors how are you
eric you've just reminded me of the
staff of the living tribunal that more
show dr strange this
is the staff of the living tribunal
otherwise why would you use a simple
baton like this why would that be the
weapon of choice now the floors of this
facility contain
vast stacks of books but there's another
interesting parallel commentary thing
about it that can find all of its
mystic cosmic multiversal wisdom into
tangible book hard copies mobius and
loki uses projector to
beam up loki from past mcu moments his
arrest in the first avengers movie which
this loki would have just experienced
but also
this famous loki pose which he actually
makes in ragnarok
[Music]
which is odd because this loki would not
have lived that yet ragnarok was like
five years after this
this tells us that rhymes
would have played out if not and notice
when loki turns away
uncomfortable we can assume that mobius
is showing him
his death in the grip of thanos infinity
war the moment i too have these two
triggered some cringes i'm sorry
okay here quarter monitors approach this
rox cart store in the pouring like
roxanne this is probably the scene we
saw the set photos of earlier this year
roxcart has the same roxxx says roxanne
the energy conglomerate that has
appeared in the background of past
marvel films i'm wondering if that oil
company might have branched out in the
future into
retail like other science fiction has
shown you know the futuristic
by and large store that ruined earth and
quality notice these troopers appear to
come from these glowing doors
these could be the portals through which
they travel together nice
elevator doors look like on the other
side now watching them on the other side
that we saw earlier again i do think
that's dean martino possibly lady loki
whom we know from set photos was part of
this sequence but notice
near patio goods is that groaning robot
maybe it's a waistband or a floor
cleaner or even a futurey version of
those creepy robots that stack stuff and
report spills that exist in supermarkets
right now those things you're gonna
leave me when i like cookie dough
i know you're just going to eat it ralph
shut up he lands back
in this elevator door-lined room
frustrated as if he just tried to escape
the tva but then
just circled right back to the starting
point now this red gate and the floor
underneath it have these blast
streaks this could be the portal that
activates where in time these elevator
doors take you and you're like i love
how the portals are powered by a tangled
mess of wires
messy and stupid it's awesome and
douglas adamson now there is
[Music]
rarely on the same page
not as you but to keep up with you
[Music]
obviously this isn't the same movement
it doesn't look like tightening but you
know that purple glow definitely reminds
me of the way he used the purple power
stone energy to shatter that moon before
he threw it either way he's sitting
below
waiting for this death melancholia style
by a pair of royal
types some believe this was natasha
romanoff no no no this is sophia
d'artina's character meaning we are
seeing her at the very end of her
timeline after the universe has just
been wiped out next clip
okay here we see loki standing up in the
midst of a similar post-apocalyptic
chaos but that is devastated new york
behind him including
avengers tower
oh interesting that's a bag of money
it's transferred to this flight
attendant as loki watches on and shades
yes loki is db cooper here in case you
don't know who d
cooper is he is the infamous mystery man
if that was even his name in 1971 he
extorted a two hundred thousand dollar
ransom
he hijacked northwest orient airlines
flight 305
from portland to seattle and then he
parachuted
out and was never found all they thought
of them was a few banknotes found out
i love that dude that's cool
this series is going to use historical
fiction yeah justify all these crazy
mysteries of human history maybe they're
going to say the mandela effect
occurrences that have come up
whether the berenstain bears or sin has
been in a gene movie
all of these could have just been caused
by loki's wrists in the timeline there's
a really cool one of these that comes up
at the end of the trailer
stay tuned loki then runs on the surface
of that same purple planet as the moon
looms down on them
toward this interesting looking shack it
is stamped with the number 21 oh
jacket reads variant maybe the tv agents
have to wear certain clothes when they
explore these variant timelines like the
adjustment bureau with that hat rule
and then swings this woman around this
setting does look familiar to me and
their architecture is similar
though those are roman numerals behind
them
it looks like that would be 79. kind of
like that number 21 on the shack maybe
the tba access points are numbered and
whatever the historical numerical system
is
now the craziest set of this trailer is
this red and white striped room
vines over growing everything i'm
assuming this is some kind of loki
throne room because there is a throne
with an
l over it but this place is a total [ __ ]
show there's a shower stall there's
lamps there's all kinds of odds and ends
it's like a junkyard it honestly kind of
feels like an evil lair that a future
version of loki
has crafted for himself after screwing
over a bunch of timelines and
hoarding random craftsmen up all those
things like
1985 b biff loki gets to be president in
this one
also notice how one of the fighters
swings a weapon that looks like a
knockoff mule mirror like in this
version this thor
counterpart is this underling next clip
yeah yeah here is loki's amazing dvd
cooper jump with
heimdall catching them with the bicross
that explains it so it does kind of
sound like it
silva's heimdall is back to live again
which does make sense right because in
these alternate timelines infinity war
has not yet happened
and i love how they leave a few bills
behind the ones authorities would have
found in the river
[Applause]
perfect
come on what did you expect
these flickering typefaces reflect the
alternate time periods and timelines
that show will hop in and out of this
floor wallpaper
caked weathered stone scratch gold
wooden paneling but what i love about a
lot of these
you can actually match these letters
together as there exists a version of
the loki title where it's all wooden or
all emeralds it's kind of like a rubik's
cube with all these different letters
oh neato trying to line up the typefaces
but unable to
oh neato whatever shut up
again with loki suited up with this loki
for president button
this is a nod to the 2016 vote loki
comic series in which loki runs for
president on the platform that he had
the guts to lie to everyone
it's a great series you gotta check it
out now his traitorous companions are
delightfully costumed one wears a
license plate shirt one is a helmet
has a helmet with a curved bike
handlebars but then
this arcade game my favorite details
olympias
yes you don't know about this like db
cooper polybius is another element
deeply rooted in american urban
languages
the game itself never existed or did it
in the early 2000s internet forums began
to talk about how there was this game
called polybius in 1981
in the portland suburbs that caused
psychoactive and addictive effects in
whoever played it
and these game boxes were later visited
by mysterious men in black to gather
data from the machines
the problem is there was no actual
evidence of this game ever really
existing it's just one of these fun
internet stories but now we have the
evidence it was like
it was always located yeah politics is
just another great example of how this
series is plugging a lot of mischief
into the mischief and unexplained
phenomena of history and i am here for
it look i'm going to be breaking down
all of the trailers we got at disney's
investor day but there is a lot to talk
about thank you for your patience check
out our great merch options at
norocstarsmerch.com subscribe to
rockstars hit that notification button
follow me at ea possible and rock stars
see
you next time bye oh let's go so you
just started off with the easiest one
yeah yeah yeah the easiest one he got it
out of the way
[Laughter]
let me warm up with loki and then i'll
get the really complicated ones out of
the way
yeah my god
the first five minutes of this i was
like i was am i am i
watching tennant again oh no that's what
the show's gonna leave you more confused
what is the timeline marvel's getting
freaking
weird and i love it i love it
they're using their shows to get super
duper bizarre
in the same way how i love how dc has
used that to their advantage
with shows like doom patrol to get wild
wacky bizarre
and weird it looks like they're really
doing that with
all their shows one thing i really took
notice of is yeah because i didn't
notice that stained glass until moments
before eric pointed out here with
mephisto
it seems like they're really building to
the supernatural
hell world of mephisto i mean we're
hearing rumors and speculations about it
being linked to doctor strange
multiverse of madness
really strong theories that he's really
the villain
the ultimate endgame villain of
wandavision series as well
ghost rider they're working on getting
here blade's coming up
it just seems like mafista is the one
they're really building
it seems like the next wave it's like
we're already kind of knees deep
waist deep in the magic and time travel
side of the universe and now it's time
to really rouse
the hellish i gotta say though eric wow
my
my head kind of hurts after this one it
really does
there's just there's just so much
details
this is like a masterpiece of breakdowns
i'm like oh my god we were only at the
marvel logo and we're
five minutes into this
i don't under like how does how this is
the first time i had to like question
eric's mind
how does this guy's brain work and how
late were you up just
cackling to yourself before you fell
asleep out of pure exhaustion
i mean we've been on new rock stars a
couple of times it's videos like this
why i'm always intimidated before we go
on
of like i just gotta have fun
because i don't know how you like how'd
you
oh my god i was just in my head this
whole time like the science
the philosophy the comics ever the
previous movies
my god the the mobius call the mobius
mobius yeah for the inverted strip oh
that was brilliant
that was brilliant and i love whenever
like oh my god mc you had that planet
here the whole time
and that feels like a true easter egg oh
absolutely something i never picked up
on
i never even learned about or maybe i
didn't i just my mind just forgot it but
that's what i mean it's like
how do you remember yeah how do you like
you can't just all be google searches or
do like eric snyder
they unplug him at the end of every day
to let him cool down before plugging him
back in again he knows to look at it and
the editors send you rockstars
get this up i'm like how do you how did
you do this
could you get this done
like when you're watching a trailer
where is your eye focusing because mine
is usually on the face of whatever the
subject
character is and i have a feeling that
yours is like like
inside out peripheral vision where you
see everything on the edges first
too much too much i mean good catch on
the mongolian crash at the beginning
because
i did think of the iron man uh
similarities yeah he should have
transported there smoothly and that's
why i am wondering if it is from a
different moment but from what i gather
from
your breakdown alone it did have me
thinking of
all the different weirdness going to be
exploring
but how this will also complement the
other series that are coming out like
falcon winter soldier seems like the
most straightforward one whereas
something like with the what ifs and one
division
and multiverse of madness being the
movie that's gonna deal with a lot of
reality manipulation and such it seems
like loki
is kind of like this hybrid of what ifs
and wanda vision
the what-if scenarios between what
you've seen here like the avengers tower
in ruins of possibly a loki timeline
where he did win
at the events of avengers assemble for
her like
a situation where he has to track down
lady loki or something like that
and i love that if they do like i i
heard lady loki would be in the show and
then when i
saw the trailer the other day it did
have me thinking that was probably lady
loki
i didn't believe any of those theories
going around that it would be black
widow i didn't even think about that in
terms of
that's who he'd be hired to hunt is the
lady loki after the events of ragnarok
that could explain
why they're showing him footage of oh
yeah
ragnarok and this is the outfit you you
sport and then eventually you die
before that this version of you formed
or maybe after his death this version of
him formed the spiritual female version
of him came to be and that's who he has
to hunt down now
and i really love that concept if he if
lady loki is the person he has to hunt
down he's the only one who can do it
that just
sounds like damn good television if you
ask me
man i mean because yeah it's like you
have your main character going up
against somebody who probably has a lot
of the same
tricks up their sleeve who knows them
inside and out at least from like a
you know spiritual point and then you
also have the personal aspect of like
you're
also me how i deal with that you know
that seems like a good potential i don't
know what lady loki's personality
is really gonna be like because at least
in
these little images that we're getting
it seems so ominous
who is this where's loki we know is the
god of mischief you know i don't know if
she's gonna have that same level of
glee we'll see we'll see right now it is
as far as what we're getting so far it
looks cool
so yeah my main takeaways would be the
lady loki plot the amount of crazy
manipulation and what-if scenarios we're
gonna be seeing going on i love the
historical fiction filling and the time
gap stuff i didn't know the db cooper
story and i saw that was like our top
comment on on
our reaction was loki was db cooper how
do you know db cooper was and he
explained it here and then the arcade
game
polybius yeah that's freaky that's
awesome it's
so so rick and morty like yeah i mean
one of my favorite
remnants of working in like horror-based
print media was we would always
like throughout the month mine those
exact kinds of stories like this weird
video game that
has a conspiracy around it and what you
find out is there are tons of those in
our history and that's one thing that
honing in on they are like the mischief
of history to me in a way
in the way that they're engrossing and
so i love that aspect coming in here too
like it looks like you could have
something that is very
in the marvel no with lady loki
potentially at least and also i i like
that he mentioned kang
uh the conqueror too because you know we
know he's coming to the mcu
and is an issue for the time variants
authority they're gonna be doing a lot
of
crossing over and stuff like that so i
wonder too how that's gonna play in but
yeah it really does feel like you're
encapsulating both the mischief side and
some of the grit that will use tom
hiddleston's chops you know
i'm a big fan of the series umbrella
academy season two reaction is all up on
youtube and in that show they have a
character named five
within that world there is something
kind of similar to the tva called the
bureau
they monitor timelines and stuff what i
notice whenever we do a lot of timeline
stuff what we usually do is go into like
the jfk thing that's that's usually like
who really killed jfk what happened
there
and even umbrella academy explores
that's like a big part of the season two
plot
here i love that they're doing a little
bit more deeper cut ones yeah well once
you're like i don't know db cooper i
mean i know a lot of you guys do but i
don't or this arcade game like these
these are smaller things to explore
maybe they will do the jfk thing
i love that they're going to be having
more fun and doing all these other
avenues as well
as it stands man this one blew my mind
like there's this is one i'd have to
keep rewatching because when you start
getting into numbers and math and all
that i'm like i'm lost
it's okay my mind just starts going dude
you're stupid you're stupid
all the elevator buttons and we'll be
the ones and then you will come to our
video eric voss
all right guys well subscribe to new
rockstars if you haven't done so already
trust me with all the hype of all these
movies coming out through the channel
the go-to
click that notification bell for us
subscribe hit that like button and last
but not least
flev doran a friend i've been happy
to get to know a lot more as of late
he lives in romania and over there they
have this holiday they celebrate that he
informed me about it's kind of like a
combination of halloween and christmas
called saint nicholas where kids get
lots of candy in their
boots so he's gonna spoil his nephew got
some birthdays coming up there's a whole
bunch of
celebrations of you know christmas new
year's so many things for him to
celebrate right now
so flev with that in mind i hope you
have an amazing holiday season hope you
don't
blow your hand off with all the
fireworks you're planning on setting off
shoot your eye out kid i just want you
to have a great time with your family to
keep on
bonding because that's what matters most
this time of year it's been a rough year
for everyone based off your enthusiastic
message you sent my way
i'm happy to like it's crazy to feel
such
energy and positivity being received
from text that's rare i love your
enthusiasm buddy and uh
merry christmas or happy saint nicholas
i don't know what the hell you guys say
dude to your you and your whole family
you have a great one
and get some new year's resolutions in
mind maybe get some ass implants
[Music]